Well so, there's a couple a ways to think about it,
but let me just kind of go top down. So, here's what I'm
thinking. I think the same principle applies, where you sort of want to
ask the question that gives you the maximum amount of information. And
from the teacher's point of view, I might be able to
pick a question that gives you the answer right away, depending upon
what h is and what x is. But from the learner's point
of view, I sort of can't. So what does the learner know?
>> So, when we ask a question,
x, it's going to either have a yes answer. Or a no
answer. And let's say that at any given point in time,
we have n possible people that we're trying to reason about.
And then after we choose x, after we choose the question,
if the answer is yes then we're going to have, I don't
know, some other number of people. Let's say l. And if
the answer is no then it's going to be n minus l,
right? And so you said that in the case of the teacher,
pick a question so that this yes is going to whittle it
down so that this is just going to be the one right answer.
>> That's exactly right. That, that's assuming that x is set up
in such a way that you could ask that kind of question.
>> Basically a question could be of the form, is it this or this or this
or this or this? Any pattern of answers
that we want, we can construct the corresponding question.
>> Okay, that makes sense to me and I don't think it changes, my
thought process, so, so, that's good. So
I always want to ask the question that's going to
give me maximum information. I'm the learner.
I don't know, everything like the teacher does,
but what I do know are all of my hypotheses. Alright. So I know how
each hypothesis responds to each of the
questions. So, in general, it seems to me
that I should try to eliminate as many
hypotheses as I can, okay? That makes sense?
>> Yeah, I'll write that down. I like that.
>> Now, you could say,
that's what the teacher did. But, let's take what the teacher did,
the teacher knew that there was a hypothesis where it would whittle
it down that, since the answer was yes, it would whittle it
down to one. But if the answer had been no, it would have
only gotten rid of one. So since the teacher knew the answer
the teacher could pick that question. But as a learner, I don't know
the answer, so finding questions that whittle it down to one if
the answer is yes aren't very helpful because the answer might be no.
>> Alright
so how many. Let's see so under the assumption the
target hypothesis was chosen from H say, uniformly at random.
>> Right.
>> What's the expected number of hypotheses we
can eliminate with a question that has this form?
>> Well, it's binary. So if you assume
that the hypothesis covers every, the hypothesis base
covers everything. Then the best you can do
is eliminate about half of them, on average.
>> Well, so, but in particular, if you have
a question like this, x. That, you now, you ask
it when there's n possible people. And then, after
you ask it if the answer is yes, you're
at l possible people. And otherwise, you're at n
minus l. Which branch are we going to go down?
>> Well, we don't know. It could be either one.
>> ha. But do, can we put a probability on it?
>> Yes if it covers everything. It's about a half
and a half. You said it was uniform, right? Uniformly chosen?
>> The, the right answer, the, the target person is uniformly
chosen. But this question isn't, isn't necessarily of that form, right?
This, this question could be very skewed, it might only have one thing
on the left. And n minus 1 on the right like you said.
>> Right, well then I, that's not a very good question to ask.
>> No, that's right. But I wanted, I
want to be able to distinguish good from bad questions
by saying we want questions that, that, that are
going to leave us with the smallest expected size set.
>> Oh, well then since all possibilities are there, the smallest
the, the best you can hope for is about a half.
>> Yeah, and in particular, eh, with this,
this particular question's going to do, is it's going to have a probability
of n over l of going down the left branch and getting
an l. And it's going to have a probability of n minus l
over n of going down the right branch and getting n minus
l. And so that could be one way of actually scoring this,
this quesiton The question that has the best score, as you pointed
out, is going to be one where l is about the same as
n minus l, in fact, half would be a really good choice.
>> Right, I thought that's what
I said.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, okay, good.
>> But, but I just wanted to write down the formula.
>> Okay, that makes sense, that makes sense. Okay, no,
it's always good to write down the formula. Okay, so
you want to pick questions that roughly split things in half.
And if you can do that every single time, then every
single time, you will split the set in half. So
you'll start out with n, then n over 2, then n
over 4, then n over 8, then n over, and
eventually you'll get to n over n which will give 1.
So you'll only have one, possible answer. And
so that'll take you a logarithm amount of time.
>> Right, so the number of times you can divide
a number in half before you get down to one
is exactly the log base two. So if we start
with size of h hypothesis, it will take us like log
base two to whittle it down to a single question.
This is a lot larger. I mean this is a
nice small number, but it's a lot larger than one,
right? You know, one, one is really great. This is you
know, exponentially, no, this is much, much worse than one. But
but it's still really good. You can, you know, it's not
considering all the hypothesis. It's very cleverly whittling it down so
that it only has to look at the log of that.
>> Right.